I'm an introvert for sure as I have a
career despite myself when I grow up I
want to be famous I want to be a star I
want to be in movies when I grow up I
want to see the world drive nice cars I
want to have groupies it's why I started
out as a comedian I started out to make
people happy and make people feel good
every single day that I do my show it is
an energy that is like no other energy
never follow someone else's path unless
you're in the woods and your loss you
see a path and by all means you should
follow that nobody want to hire me for
three years I didn't have any offers
she's an American comedian TV host
writer and producer she starred in a
popular sitcom Ellen and hosted the
Ellen DeGeneres Show she's won 13 Emmys
and 14 People's Choice Awards she's
Ellen DeGeneres and here is my take on
her top ten rules for success rule
number one is my personal favorite and
I'm curious to figure out which one you
guys like the best - I get the distinct
impression that while you may be this
famous talk-show host you are a private
person maybe even shy I'm an introvert
for sure as I have a career despite
myself because I really am awkward
socially I hate going to big events I
hate having to do small talk I don't
like a lot of attention
it's bold of you being an introvert -
not only do this show but to also put
yourself out there realizing that not
everyone's going to like it
if it cost me you know some viewers and
if it cost me some money I'd rather talk
about what I think is important than
just be you know vanilla and and try to
be liked by everybody that honesty has
coasters especially in 1997 when she
famously came out of the closet I'm gay
only to have Hollywood shut the door
advertisers pulled out within a year her
sitcom was canceled her careers stopped
cold I don't think was a failure but it
certainly gave me a lot of free time for
three years to sit still and go okay Who
am I without a career Who am I without
people loving me did you feel that you
had made a mistake in coming out
absolutely no
absolutely not it's the best because I'm
I am free I'm completely able to be
exactly who I am to have to hide
anything it's just a horrible way to
live when I was younger I thought
success was something different I
thought when I grow up I want to be
famous I want to be a star I want to be
in movies when I grow up I want to see
the world drive nice cars I want to have
groupies to quote the Pussycat Dolls how
many people thought it was boobies by
the way it's not it's groupies but my
idea success is different today and as
you grow you'll realize definition of
success changes for many of you today
success is being able to hold down 20
shots of tequila for me the most
important thing in your life is to live
your life with integrity and not to give
in to peer pressure to try to be
something that you're not to live your
life as an honest and compassionate
person to contribute in some way this
energy I mean you can feel it in here
you and you've talked to you know people
come from very very far away they they
fly here they make you know a plant and
this is their vacation or their tripping
and they come in here and bring this
positive energy and this love and this
joy and I get to feel that every single
day it's the most amazing feeling that
that energy is coming at me every day
and I and I hope I give it back to them
and I hope they get that and I think if
I do that every single day and I keep it
I feel like I have a purpose I feel like
I am it's why I started out as a
comedian I started out to make people
happy and make people feel good and I'm
doing it on a larger scale and and I
think if I hope I can do this for a long
long long time during front of an
audience all the time this is a big deal
it's the gospel what's the difference oh
there's a big difference that that
audience comes to see me and they travel
from and God bless them they travel from
all over the world to come to a taping
and they wait for a year for tickets
they're my core group of people that get
me know me and and love me and and I
feel that and I you know that's that
room is like church I mean that really
in every single day that I do my show it
is an energy that is like no other
energy
the way you are with your audience is
unlike I think anything I've ever seen I
mean they really feel that they are they
are a part of the of the show yeah yeah
they are I mean this is our 11th season
and when we started building the studio
it was really important that the
audience was comfortable and it was
really important that they were not in
the dark that they were lit because
they're part of the show it's not a
spotlight on me of course mine lighting
is better I'm a cover girl I have to
look good but but it's still bright
enough that they're part of it you know
you did a very successful sitcom you
then came out and then it was cancelled
it has just this show sort of saved you
do you think in a way I think what saved
me is me being honest and I think I
somehow had the courage to do something
and say something that I knew would
would possibly in my career and instead
of making business more important
I made my soul and my my life more
important and I think by by being
truthful and by being honest that saved
me and then I was given the opportunity
to do something where I could actually
just be myself and people can see Who I
am and if they respond to it great and
if they don't great and they've
responded follow your passion stay true
to yourself never follow someone else's
path unless you're in the woods and your
loss and you see a path and by all means
you should follow
don't give advice it'll come back and
bite you and they ask don't take
anyone's advice so my advice to you is
to be true to yourself and everything
will be fine and I know that a lot of
you are concerned about your future but
there's no need to worry the economy is
booming the job market is wide open the
planet is just fine
it's going to be great you've already
survived a hurricane what else can
happen to you and as I mentioned before
some of the most devastating things that
happen he will teach you the most and
now you know the right what the right
questions to ask for your first job
interview like is it above sea level
so to conclude my conclusion that I've
previously concluded in the common
cement speech I guess what I'm trying to
say is life is like one big Mardi Gras
but instead of showing your boobs show
people your brain and if they like what
they see you'll have more beads than you
know what to do with do you carry any
resentment from that time furious
you are crazy at the time though I was
furious at the time you know because you
know when you're new when you all of a
sudden they're like you know I just felt
like I was it was my own fault I kind of
felt like I was stuck you know living my
life the way and then if I if I you know
how dare they not like me anymore just
because I suddenly revealed the truth of
you know who I am in one aspect of my
life not you know it's just I'm just
saying I'm gay that's all I was saying
and and I was so mad I was so mad that I
lost you know my show I lost not not
just my show but like nobody would to
hire me for three years I didn't have
any offers no and I mean literally the
phone did not ring for three three years
and and I had no money I was out of
money I was just so that tends to make
people cranky and and then you know I
just kind of it was good it was a it was
actually I'm very grateful for that time
I'm very grateful that I got to
experience it gave me more compassion I
know what it feels like to be out of
money I know what it feels like to be up
and high and like you know I was at a
top-rated sitcom and very successful and
people treated me very well and then all
of a sudden just because of one
revelation I just was I was the joke
every pn i was a punchline of every
late-night talk show i was made fun of
in magazines i was it was and it felt
horrible at the time and now I look back
and I'm so grateful for it because it it
really gave me a chance to examine
myself and say who are you without Fame
who are you without success who are you
without money and I kind of found
different parts of me that would not
have grown
had I not experienced that most comedy
is based on getting a laugh at somebody
else's expense and I
that that's just a form of bullying in a
major way so I want to be an example
that you can be funny and be kind and
make people laugh without hurting
somebody else's feelings the big
breakthrough was in 1986 you're on with
Johnny Carson first time with Johnny
Carson and he loved you and you did a
routine about callin God on the phone
right I think you put you on hold didn't
he well it was a big place you know
people talk about praying and talking to
God all the time but I just thought it
would be great if you could have a phone
conversation if you could actually just
reach God somehow if you could just pick
up the phone and call God if you were
calling God today what would you say
thank you all right just I got nothing
but gratitude my whole life my whole
life is just I'm so blessed I'm so lucky
and I feel it every day I was talking to
some of your audience before the show
today and I asked them what they loved
about you and what they said unanimously
was your energy and your dancing where
did the dancing start it really started
as such a ridiculous accident it was
kind of you know when I even when I did
my sitcom
when I was introduced to the audience
before we would take the show I just
have always loved music and I always
loved to dance
I mean how do you not dance when you
hear music that's just sort of Who I am
when I hear music I dance and then it
became where I would dance into the
audience and and and then it just kind
of saw the audience respond to it in a
way that it freed them up to to just
dance with me and I think people come
here almost it doesn't really matter
who's on the show it's just a place to
let go and be free and I mean everyone
in this audience is you know a stranger
to the other people are from all over
the world and they come here it's
daytime it's it's you know it's not dark
in here they're not drunk as far as I
know
they maybe I don't know but and and
they're all dancing
made me thirsty
you know people just stop dancing making
people grow up and they stop playing
games they stop playing hide and seek
they stop you know we just grow up and
we get so serious and stop playing and
we stop dancing and and you know we get
busy with our lives and the only time we
dance is maybe at a wedding and maybe if
we're drunk and maybe if there's 20
other people out there and you know
nobody goes to clubs anymore and so it's
a place to just you know and to me
dancing represents just freedom and
letting go and having fun and being a
kid again so I think that's why they
respond to it and that's why I do it
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Juliette Cole asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you I made a profile next leave in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know which of Ellen's
top 10 rules had the biggest impact on
you and why leave it in the comments I
will join in the discussion thank you
again for watching continue to believe
or whatever your one word is and I'll
see you soon